bonsoir à tous alors moi je vais aussi
commencé par une question est ce qu'il
ya des joueurs de jeux vidéo dans la
salle alors est pas mal je pensais pas
autant
j'ai 24 ans et comme beaucoup de jeunes
de ma génération j'ai été baigné dans
les jeux vidéo a dès l'âge de 5 ans donc
j'ai commencé avec les consoles à jouer
sur les consoles ensuite j'ai eu un
ordinateur j'ai commencé à jouer sur un
ordinateur et finalement à 12 ans j'ai
découvert des jeux vidéo en ligne dont
un fameux jeu vidéo dont vous avez sans
doute plus dé tous entendu vaguement si
ce n'est un peu mieux parler world of
warcraft
alors entendu parler en bien ou en mal
on connaît des médias traditionnels il
aime bien des fois diabolisent les
impôts les jeux vidéo vont pouvoir voir
caf la passion qu'est ce que c'est c'est
tout simple c'est un jeu de rôle
massivement multijoueur en ligne le
principe est le suivant vous incarnez un
personnage et avec ce personnage vous
allez partir à l'aventuré pour réaliser
des quêtes je suis et des monstres
récupérer des objets ce dans un monde
virtuel ouvert à tous les autres joueurs
c'est à dire que vous allez croiser
d'autres joueurs sur votre route vous
groupé avec eux et partir avec d'autres
joueurs à l' aventure c'est c'est le jeu
de rôle en ligne le plus connu de
l'histoire du jeu vidéo et il a sans
doute déjà marqué l'histoire et on en
entendra peut-être pareil dans 50 ans
dans les livres d'histoire qui s'est
donc moi j'ai grandi avec les jeux vidéo
et j'ai également grandi avec
l'avènement d'internet dans les foyers
ce qu'on appelle la génération internet
à 12 ans internet a débarqué chez moi à
la maison
peut-être pas forcément que plaisir à
mes parents quand ils voyaient les
factures à la fin du mois parce qu'à
l'époque ont payé à la consommation et
donc j'ai doucement découvert parce que
c'était le fait de jouer en ligne mais
aussi le fait d'aller sur des sites
internet et des forums de discussion ces
lieux où on partage on part de notre
passion avec d'autres internautes
et bien pour parler de jeux vidéo pas
seulement pour jouer mais aussi pour
vous pour dire bah voilà qu'est ce que
j'ai pensé du dernier jeu ou même pour
aider d'autres joueurs qui étaient
bloqués dans un certain niveau pour leur
donner la petite astuce qui leur
permettait de passer ce niveau de tuer
tel ennemi et de réussir le jeu vidéo et
c'est donc ça finalement kim a doucement
mais sûrement en tant qu'autodidacte
amené sur la piste des sites internet je
me suis dit mais tiens je vais sur ses
formes discussions pour partager ses
astuces pour aider d'autres joueurs
pourquoi pas créer un site où je
retrouve toutes mes astuces toutes mes
connaissances pour aider tout le monde
mais dont j'ai créé mon premier site à
l'âge de 15 ans en autodidacte en
apprenant sur internet comment est-ce
qu'on verra si j'ai appris ça sur
internet
comment est-ce qu'on crée des images des
bannières comme en ce qu'on fait du
graphisme j'ai appris ça sur internet et
non j'ai créé mon premier site à 15 ans
la mamie tring point com qui aujourd'hui
un site d'actualités sur world war iv
que je vous ai présenté tout à l'heure
et donc sur ce site j'ai commencé par
faire et bien quelques bosses pour
expliquer certaines astuces d'enjeu mais
ça c'était au début
doucement doucement et puis avec le
temps au fil des mois au fil des années
j'ai créé de plus en plus de portes à la
fin vous je crée ce même plus au jeu
c'est complètement fou parce que je
passais mon temps sur internet à vouloir
aider tout le monde à vouloir et bien
expliquer quelles sont les nouveautés
dans le jeu parce qu'il faut savoir vos
c'est presque un monde à part entière
tant il ya de nouveautés chaque jour il
ya de quoi écrire plusieurs articles
comme vous quand vous lisez votre
journal régional delà c'est presque à
comment journal régional devoir de rares
cas et donc au fil de ces années
neuf ans plus tard maintenant suis
finalement la tête d'un réseau de sites
internet dédiés à ces jeux vidéo qui
accueille c'est incroyable je n'en
reviens pas moi-même quand j'ai aussi
des tirs 50 milles
visiteurs par jour il ya cinquante mille
personnes qui viennent chaque jour pour
lire ses astuces ou avoir les dernières
infos sur le jeu sachant qu'au début je
me souviens j'avais 18 ans je terminais
mon bac c'était en terminale et je
disais à mes parents voir où il ya eu
300 personnes sur mon site aujourd'hui
c'est un truc de fou
aujourd'hui on a cinquante mille c'est
un truc encore plus fou tout ça
finalement qui va mener être un des plus
grands réseaux de sites de jeux vidéo en
france malgré moi parce qu'à la base je
suis un passionné qui voulait juste
aider quelques internautes et plus je me
suis retrouvé maintenant avec 50000
visiteurs par jour vous expliquerez
peut-être un peu plus tard ce qui a fait
la les clés du succès de cette aventure
puisque on va passer au deuxième
chapitre
parce qu'en plus des sites internet j'ai
commencé à faire des vidéos sur internet
youtube
vous connaissez sans doute tous cette
plateforme de vidéos sur internet
n'importe qui peut envoyer sa vidéo
qu'elle soit sérieuse marrante
pédagogique et tout le monde va les
regarder les biens mois ou un jour
j'étais d'université c'était en 2010 je
faisais des études d'informatique est
bon les études d'informatique ça peut
être passionnant mais ça peut être aussi
plutôt chiant je suis désolé pour le
port que j'avais à l'époque mais c'était
vraiment très très chiant et
j'étais avec un camarade de classe qui
était je trouve ça chiant aussi mais
quitte les passionnés de l'audiovisuel
et il était plutôt talentueux m'avez
démontré ses créations je lui ai dit
mais tu y as s'appelle prend quoi il
s'appelle comme ça que s'il est toujours
tient françois moi j'ai toujours voulu
faire une émission vidéo sur grand
warcraft ce jeu sur internet pour donner
mes conseils et mes astuces non plus on
écrit sur un titre mais en vidéo
en parlant donc d'autres joueurs moi le
joueur qui donne des astuces aux joueurs
est-ce que tu trouve l'idée intéressante
midi ouai c'est trop bien bien on quitte
la classe en rétro mais une vidéo
donc on est parti de cours vraiment
désolé pour le professeur et on est allé
dans mon petit appartement
on a préparé a vite fait un petit truc
en deux heures on a tourné la première
édition de 15 minutes
et là quelques jours plus tard il y
avait déjà trente mille visionnages
franchement on ne s'attendait pas à ça
c'était même c'était en décembre 2010
nous souvient c'était au moment des
fêtes de noël
voeux de fin d'année et à l'époque il y
avait des tops vidéo on était en toc
vidéo on était même devant les voeux de
bonne année de notre cher président
nicolas sarkozy donc on était en effet
plutôt faire et donc quand on voit la
démission de mam meeting c'est comme ça
que tu as appelé mon pseudo c'est ma
vitrine on a appelé sa démission de mam
eating qu'on n'est pas allé chercher
plus loin et c'était simple c'était mon
petit journal sur youtube pour les
passionnés de vendoire carte vous ont
présenté les dernières informations les
dernières les actualités et puis les
petites astuces du jeu alors on a
poursuivi l'aventuré pendant 6 mois ou
chaque vendredi on sortait un nouvel
épisode ça de façon régulière c'est très
important je reviendrai dessus
cela fait partie des clés du succès et
puis au terme de six mois d'émission on
avait déjà atteint un million
en visionnage sur youtube et ce qui a
fait je pense la clé du succès puisque
n'importe qui peut finalement faire une
vidéo sur youtube
n'importe qui peut se filmer et dire ce
qu'ils pensent futur ci a fait la clé du
succès c'est déjà d'avoir trouvé
françois mon réalisateur qui était très
pro dans sa façon de faire c'est à dire
que l'emballage était professionnel
depuis mon moi dans ma façon de
présenter des choses j'ai toujours
essayé d'être proche avec les joueurs
j'ai toujours rappeler que bah moi je
n'était autre que comme tous ceux qui me
regardait un simple joueur passionné du
jeu tu voulais juste de véhiculer et
bien ma passion pour le jeu donné mes
petites astuces mais je n'étais pas un
super héros du jeu vidéo
non pas du tout je n'ai pas un champion
et c'est cette proximité avec la
communauté est peut-être la simplicité
que j'avais à présenter des choses qui a
fait de plus en plus de gens ont
commencé à à suivre mes vidéos et j'en
suis arrivé aujourd'hui quatre ans plus
tard à avoir réalisé 339 vidéo conduit
certains beaucoup mais à certaines
vidéos ont pris moins de temps que
d'autres sites
une vidéo tous les quatre jours si j'ai
bien calculé 5 millions de visionnages
en tout sur youtube
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que ce
qui était au départ un petit coup de
tête lors d'un coup on a fait ça dans le
studio ça m'a aussi permis de voyager
puisque on est parti aux états unis pour
tourner des vidéos en islande en
allemagne et je suis même pas en suisse
aujourd'hui pour vous parler de tout ça
donc cette aventure qui m'a permis de
vivre beaucoup de choses et si je peux
me permettre ce qui est marrant dans
toute cette histoire c'est que au départ
j'étais quelqu'un de très timide
à l'école je détestais parler devant la
classe c'est plutôt rigolo maintenant je
parle devant je ne sais pas mon
auditoire de 150 200 personnes mais je
n'aurais jamais cru que j'allais y
parvenir un jour
est-ce qu'il faut savoir quand je me
suis lancée dans les vidéos
tout le monde disait mais tu te montres
sur internet tout le monde va te voir on
va critiquer ta coupe de cheveux parce
que non j'ai
non mais je les vois pas très bien donc
oui on m'a pris beaucoup de remarques
sur la coupe de cheveux mais je disais
mais bon c'est pas grave si ça fait
rigoler les gens c'est tant mieux et
puis finalement ces gens qui me
regardent ce sont d'autres personnes
derrière leur écran je le rencontrerai
jamais dans la vraie vie comme on dit
chez les gamers dans la vie et donc
c'est pas grave et finalement ça m'a
complètement décomplexés et ça m'a
permis de prendre confiance en moi de ne
pas avoir peur d'aborder des gens pour
discuter avec eux de ne pas avoir peur
de parler devant plusieurs personnes
alors maintenant je voulais parler tous
et ya quand même quelque chose
d'intéressant c'est le futur qu'est ce
que doivent être composés de futur parce
que je vous ai parlé des sites internet
de la génération internet de youtube
mais les nouveaux jeux à nice où est-ce
qu'ils vont ou estivants aller et bien
ce qu'il y a une chose qui est plutôt
intéressante ce qui se produit en ce
moment sur internet c'est le live
streaming c'est pas si vous en avez de
les gens quand tu parlais mais le
principe est simple c'est que n'importe
qui dans le monde peut brancher sa
caméra et faire une émission ou une
vidéo en direct c'est à dire que alors
ça peut être du jeu vidéo mais ça peut
être aussi plus d'autre chose ça peut
être une conférence un concert et il va
diffuser en direct et tout le monde va
pouvoir aller voir ce live stream sur
internet et même réagir via les
commentaires
il faut savoir que chez les joueurs il y
a un site qui s'appelle twitch peut-être
que ça vous dit quelque chose puisque
twitch cette plateforme c'est un site
internet où n'importe qui peut lancer
son jeu se filmer et diffuser ça dans le
monde entier tu as été racheté il ya
deux semaines et demie par amazon pour
la coquette somme de milliards de
dollars ses dires il ya de l'intérêt
dans la licensing et 28 ch voilà ça
permet à n'importe qui de jouer c'est
parti et de présenter ça en direct et ça
permet aux joueurs eh bien de venir
commenter donner leur avis poser des
questions en direct
et je pense que l'avenir du jeu vidéo et
de la vidéo
l'association du jeu vidéo de la vidéo
sur internet
résident dans le live streaming alors si
je devais résumer les points qui m'ont
permis de réussir sur internet il ya
trois points majeurs
c'est la régularité parce qu'il faut
savoir sur internet vous pouvez être
très rapidement mise en lumière mise en
avant pour faire le buzz comme on aime
dire des médias des jeunes mais s'il
faut savoir c'est que une fois que vous
avez fait le buzz si vous ne faites plus
rien à faire et bien vous disparaissez
dans l'anonymat encore plus rapidement
donc le fait d'être régulier le fait
d'avoir régulièrement mis en ligne des
vidéos d'avoir répondu aux questions de
la communauté
elle va ça m'a permis vingt deux de
créer ces sites avec 50000 visiteurs par
jour ces vidéos avec sa cousine
visionnage deuxième clé du succès la
passion d'un évidemment c'est tout ce
que je fais ce qui devenu finalement mon
métier c'est une histoire de passion du
début j'avais 12 ans et je découvrais
internet je suis aujourd'hui j'ai
toujours été passionné et ça c'est très
important parce que c'est un métier qui
est vraiment ou pas du tout anodin c'est
à dire que on peut passer 10 15 15
heures par jour on mais puisque c'est de
la passion on compte pas le temps et
spatiale et dernier point ce qui est
plutôt surprenant mais c'est la
déconnexion c'est vraiment important de
prendre le temps de se déconnecter de
toute cette folie et internet les écrans
et moi personnellement je suis cycliste
et j'adore des fois bien prendre mon
petit vélo est allé faire un tour de
quelques heures plus du tout être devant
un écran
ce soit surtout aujourd'hui avec les
smartphones les tablettes les télés les
pc ça me libère l'esprit et en faisant
du vélo et bien peut-être que des
nouvelles idées me viennent et pour
conclure ma présentation un petit
dernier mot mon slogan tout ce qui est
inutile et forcément indispensable bon
oui je sais j'ai choisi une photo à un
peu osé mais c'est tiré d'une de mes
vidéos
je pense que cette se soulevant que j'ai
prôné depuis le début de mon aventure
sur internet
elle résume bien tout elle résume mon
projet mais aussi les jeux vidéo parce
qu'il faut quand même à l'appeler et ça
c'est important
les jeux vidéo ils sont et pour s'amuser
c'est pas fait pour être le meilleur le
champion du monde
c 'est pour délirer pour s'amuser pour
partager avec des amis quitte à aller
faire n'importe quoi dans le jeu vidéo
et bien on peut on peut le faire et
c'est toujours ce que j'ai essayé le
prenais être simple allez on joue aux
jeux vidéo pour s'amuser et c'est
justement l'amusement qui est
indispensable dans les jeux vidéo
et voilà c'est sur ce beau petit slogan
que je vais conclure ma présentation